police investigating a crash involving a
pedestrian near the intersection of
decatur and harmon we're told a man has
died and police think that it's a hit
and run madison kimbrough live at where
we're told it happened in madison what
are we seeing there
it's still a very active scene as you
can see behind me several police cars
have blocked off this area of decatur
now as of now metro has confirmed that
the man was between 50 to 60 years old
and found lying in the travel lane on
the road of decatur south of harmon that
man did not make it to the hospital and
was pronounced dead on scene according
to police his death was a result of a
hit and run like you mentioned that
happened earlier this evening both north
and south decatur are closed from harmon
to royal ridge drive if you are headed
to this direction you will need to take
an arts alternate route keep it here on
8 news now for the latest details as we
will bring you the latest updates on air
and online reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now